vous aimez c'est légitime que l'on fasse
la différence entre le vrai travail et
l'assistanat qui irrite on le sait une
bonne partie des couches populaires mais
qui peut donner sa voix au front
national
d'abord ce n'est pas la première fois
qu'il nous raconte cette histoire
puisque en 2007 déjà il nous avait
promis la défense de la valeur travail
le travailler plus pour gagner plus et
je crois que les français ne vont pas se
faire avoir une seconde fois car que
s'est-il passé pendant cinq ans il a été
non seulement le président pas du vrai
travail il a été le président du capital
et il a été le président du vrai chômage
puisque nous avons mille chômeurs de
plus par jour et donc la question de la
valeur travail
elle est au coeur du projet de notre
candidat est au coeur du pacte
présidentiel aujourd'hui puisqu'il
s'agit d'abord et avant tout de réformer
le système bancaire pour que le système
bancaire se met au service du
développement des petites et moyennes
entreprises ce qui n'a pas été fait et
pour que lorsque les banques seront
renflouées par l'état que l'état rentre
au capital des banques donc la défense
du travail
elle se plaît en donnant aux entreprises
les moyens de se développer et créer des
emplois je vous écoute je vous
interromps sur le front national vous
faites un réquisitoire contre nicolas
sarkozy ça veut dire que vous estimez
qu'il est en partie responsable de la
percée de marine le pen
bien sûr puisqu'il est responsable de la
montée d insécurité dans tous les
domaines que ce soit la sécurité
physique au quotidien et dans les
quartiers
quel est le nombre de gens qui ont dit
on retrouve nationale parce que parce
que sur le trottoir de notre immeuble
dans notre l'immeuble maintenant on fait
les trafics de drogue sans que les paul
lapolice n'est aujourd'hui les moyens à
2002 les moyens matériels bien
et du premier tour par le front national
on n'a pas eu en 2007 sa faute et en
le front national a été contenue à 10%
voilà ça veut dire aussi qu'on assure
parler aussi en 2007 avec l'ordre juste
avec les questions de repères avec la
lutte pour la sécurité et que ses
préoccupations là ont été intégrés
ensuite par les socialistes et sont
intégrés aujourd'hui dans le projet de
françois hollande avec la question de la
sécurité que les socialistes vont
prendre à bras le corps